bonjour un belhadj merci de répondre à
nos questions sur rt france qu en israël
le ministre des finances parle d'un plan
de relance ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire combien quels secteurs
effectivement donc comme à monsieur le
ministre des finances il ya un problème
au niveau de budget il ya déjà un manque
à gagner de 8 milliards de dinars en
plus de l'impact du coup vite 19 qui est
estimé à 5 milliards de dinars donc ça
fait treize il ya du dinah alors le
problème c'est que il n'ya pas vraiment
beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre pour le
gouvernement puisque la dette est déjà à
la tête estimé le plafond estimé 7 et 72
selon la loi la loi de finances 2010
mais comme l'a dit le ministre des
finances avait des passionnés et 85%
là encore le plan de relance est
nécessaire pour la tunisie mais comme je
vous ai dis donc les marges de manoeuvre
sont limitées
mais quand même il ya il ya une
possibilité de d'établir un plan de
laurence de mobiliser des bas il faut il
faut il faut en fait beaucoup d'audace
et du courage par rapport à la
mobilisation de ressources il faut un
effort supplémentaire de mobilisation de
ressources tant interne qu'externe
donc il faut une relance des
investissements et donc au niveau de la
loi de finances actifs hic hâtives il
faut pas que le gouvernement abaisse le
budget qui est consacré le titre e on
appelle le titre 2 qui consacré aux
investissements communs comme comme a
dit le ministre il faut finir avec
l'économie dans bien entendu la
situation est difficile et et et la
situation ne va pas elle va pas
s'améliorer à très court terme donc à
très court terme il ya deux solutions
1 il faut des politiques non
conventionnelles surtout au niveau 2 de
la politique monétaire une application
beaucoup plus importants de la banque
centale surtout dans le financement
direct de budget ça du par
d'autre part moi je pense qu'il faut
quand même un certain moratoire de la
dette avec bien entendu un consensus
avec les bailleurs de fonds à
internationaux et avec les acteurs
nationaux agriculteurs en vraiment donc
en fait la sortie du ministre des
finances cette semaine c'est un appel à
effacer la dette en appelle aux
créanciers de pouvoir trouver des
solutions pour aider la tunisie ces
salles est exsangue
il ne l'a pas dit il ne l'a pas dit moi
je pense que c'est le moment
la tunisie elle doit en fait allé dans
ce sens et elle doit en fait négociés
avec ses bailleurs de fonds bilatéraux
et multilatéraux poule quand même avoir
une bouffée d'oxygène parce que parce
qu'en fait on n'oublie pas que la banque
demande et le fmi il en fait le gros
mais par exemple aller dans le sens d'un
moratoire de la dette sur les pays qui
kills encore taper difficulté sur les
pays dont l'économie fragile moi je
pense que la tunisie c'est le moment
d'aller dans ce sens et de demander
quand même avec bien entendu avec
l'accord de ses de ses créanciers et
latéraux multilatéraux pour l'avoir ce
bouffée d'oxygène
c'est juste une ou deux années maximum
après bien entendu la tunisie devra
honorer ses engagements comme comme à
l'accoutumée donc ça c'est à très court
terme et à moyen long terme il faut
comme je vous ai dit il faut en fait la
relance des investissements
il faut surtout les femmes alors
lorsqu'on parle de réformes
la mère des réformes moi je pense que
c'est les entreprises publiques et la
fiscalité
alors il faut également finir avec
l'économie de rente avec ces
autorisations
il faut également en fait lutter contre
l'économie informelle comcom a volé sa
vie qui a atteint des taux qui sont
inacceptables et il faut également un
effort de
digitalisation l'occurrence la
digitalisation de l'administration ce
sont des mesures se sont téléphone qui
sont structurels qui prennent du temps
mais il faut commencer dès maintenant
donc la situation est difficile de ces
prêts à des gaules tandis qu à surya des
solutions qui sont non conventionnelles
il faut que le gouvernement aille dans
ce sens mais à moins long terme il faut
aller dans le sens des réformes comme je
vous ai dit dans les entreprises tout
dernière question orale belhadj il ya
deux jours il ya eu dix nouveaux cas de
contamination au coin d'un virus
enregistrés en tunisie ce sont des cas
importés
on sait que le secteur du tourisme est
déjà affectée par la crise sanitaire
comment est-ce qu'il peut repartir à la
hausse on le rappelle l'impact de la
pandémie est estimé à 5 milliards de
dinars
il faut pas oublier qu'en même temps
ailleurs le ministre de la santé l'a
déclaré qu'il y avait au cas en tunisie
que la situation elle est plus ou moins
maîtrisées en sait très bien que l'eau
vive 19 il a impacté pratiquement tous
les secteurs n'ont pas seulement le
secteur du tourisme et les autres
secteurs
il faut à travailler sur des patins
effectivement est la première mesure je
pense un fonds pour les secteurs
stratégiques pour les secteurs qui
créent de la valeur il faut à moins de
ça c'est à tricoter
à moyen terme il faut un effort de
repositionnement de la tunisie dans les
chaînes de valeur et je pense que la
tunisie a tous les atours à allah les
ressources humaines nécessaires à
l'emplacement géographique nécessaire
elle a les compétences nécessaires
donc elle est incapable de se
repositionner dans les chaînes de valeur
mondiales merci redémarrer et pour une
relance de son économie
merci à rome belhadj est d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes enseignant chercheur en économie à
l'université de carthage